this place is really touristy I feel
they were awkward like we're walking
through a Mexican psi bar here hold on a
sec are you crying are you crying
[Music]
today is Christmas Day right here in
Dallas
I gotta see family Reaper traveling he
left LA with the Florida
our taxes so we're actually posting this
video first because it's Christmas you
want to mention relevant for you guys to
watch but we've actually been on this
super mega long vacation and we're
stocked on a whole bunch of footage but
it's knowing me and how can I take the
edit every time I come like let's pull
up the video between the video from us
we can't just pump it out you know how
is that no not a factory this is not a
factory it's a boutique experience of
vlogging so he's really adamant about
the fact that he wants to want to be
proceeding that's like the watch take
forever
yeah but since it is the holiday it is
Christmas we're going to throw this out
there first before we go back in time to
visit Florida and the rest of our Texas
adventure so do I get again this up
these getting milk reviews and the fact
that yes we do a blurter vlogs police
and burn the hashtag I blog based in and
for us and every temple is not for the
views really it's not really for
anything else literally sits watching
you grow up
watch this evolve as parents and as
people that you know you get the FINA
make me with a lot of like sponsors
videos and for goodness of energy fruit
that's my motto
you know that's just pretty much let me
step in if we're trying to make a living
out of it so you know thank you guys so
much for being so so supportive and all
these founders in that we've had we love
you guys so much we appreciate all the
love anything good it's good alright so
now we're gonna get started with our day
and first I wanna show you guys these
eat curry puff pastries that moment had
taught me how to make last night
Casey's favorite that's not the picture
last night of her teaching to make this
anomaly I found to get a piece of home
in LA so hopefully I can recreate it to
zoom and yes you want to help my
goodness are you have you been with
you're just in your own little world
it's okay all right last night Paula can
and I we prepared this curry beef so
this is a leftovers first thing she says
is Versace how to do this recipe junior
high she high five can identify this
fire and why can Isaac who's there
really patient what time's your wake-up
9 something with on it everyone else
like a little something even waiting two
hours yes
to do what open the presents alright the
slides hard work is done
oh my god I was amazing so are you in
the kitchen working cooking closing the
oven hot
[Music]
my permit it should be done haha yeah
alright open presents
all right let's gather around the
Christmas tree all I see all right did
you an orchestrated yeah all right
you're the person that's going to run
the Christmas opening present opening
session Joe all right what's wrong
please the biggest one
I need from Kerry oh oh I think first
president I you want to get EQ to house
oh that's the pre huggin in the photo
[Music]
you enclose dresser this one yes told
you one time it's been wanting Pokemon
cars it has a long blast I was able to
give you that joy but I think I didn't
use I asked your mother on the edge
where the show no that's what my credit
card is there is prime account sure how
to pokemon cards turn out okay still
opening it all I haven't seen this in
forever this is nostalgic put in spell
game nostalgic means it reminds me of my
childhood
Patrick it reminds me of my childhood
looking at his childhood because I
didn't quite pokemon cards eyes they
carry all nice and full yeah I was hard
Dragonball Z which was never really a
thing to begin with
alright intermission intermission forget
a face pastries I forgot about him no
the timer I never heard the timer go oh
they look good though a little puffy but
golden brown Burnham yeah and resume any
critical bit Siri autograph feature like
oh saying you can make phone calls you
just go to appointment it could as enjoy
my life is all too complicated for
another one you get a lot of presents
can we compete or the camera can see you
woo
[Music]
all four you know a lot of people love
Isaac camp on the blog channel channel I
think I have to my usual chair he's not
very dependable role literally love
being here I give this advice but her
names are you capsules I also got my
balls something very stimulated ha ha ha
heavy here look at that I didn't get him
anything
yeah yeah we I don't really oh you're
the Grinch no no no no no no no I got
there last year
I don't know you guys remember last year
Merry Christmas
can you get some love yeah doggie
material with tear stuff I have a lot of
love for all of you so I think that that
overpowered everything here on the floor
I agree I agree right the most important
thing is family so good drug yours you
can't you can't put a price on us
hanging out together in this living room
right now this is the most important
thing is just hanging out together on
Christmas Day on any given day to be
honest and material things it's just the
sugar on top it is I think said that
Santa Claus Redd Foxx who we wanted you
one yeah last one last surprise ik oh I
didn't you know I'm it just came out in
time can you meet you I wanna play house
is it reputa Merry Christmas
hey this means he has the extras good
okay yeah this is for you madam four
more
yay I don't feel like ending okay oh
really got a new bag a defrost my friend
someone I did rehearse it from the one I
always need them begin you another 100
you've been unknown you marry Chris
gonna read it yeah we get out loud Merry
Christmas baby I hope you won't be
disappointed by the by the way the lack
of good i like linda's day my lack of a
Tiffany's and co-product is Christmas
know but I'm not I'm telling it as an
expensive tradition it's okay thank you
I know that is our tradition but I hope
this new by hexa spices on by the way
clean your schedule for spring break
because we're going to pad three of us
oh my it's time to finally found a
wedding
oh right now I'm gonna tear up love you
Merry Christmas oh my god is night night
you find a pair you know plan our
wedding I'm so excited
[Music]
oh you're welcome
you can keep the knees curry pub for new
be discontented preposition presents are
open pictures ever taken video has been
recorded smiles up and smiles stomachs
have not been filled now it's time to go
eat we're gonna we're gonna go eat them
yeah alright so every year we come to
Dallas we always come to this part I
don't even know what this park is called
it's just a tradition now we we every
year we got a visit how does a little
thing just be welcome be yourself
everyone love you I'm very teeny taken
oh my goodness people hurt so what did
it mine I don't especially in this
beautiful well how did I get cranky
yeah seeing it all the time this is
that's why you're taking advantage
became jacket okay oh my gosh again like
last year last year on Christmas Day
yeah I think you also fell yeah on the
bridge
on the tan and instagramming oh let's do
it again cake this time I have a good
angle I have a good angle right here
this is this point and what happened
yeah reading exit from us today
don't wear reduce rap stick yeah I
wanted Jackie you could join it nah not
good we're talking about you peach salsa
oh yeah
I don't know I like shuffling do you
think I'm drunk
my face red no no it can't be
I feel like I'm college guy
awesome I'm awesome yeah he's awesome
thank you your honor - yes because I'm
more than who you are because we made
you that's what often is run from the
blood
okay because in the bug gun that your
English accent you know going quick
Thank You chef
that's a nice British accent I can't do
it great
oh sorry British you're doing is on
action music too
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
so carries learning how to fly a drone
cool
yeah you like it Jerry I think so well
again she wanted you stare up at it for
ya
was it hard to control it you be like hi
papi Oh
yeah it feels really really hard
Casey we needed to login her life we had
bring so much happiness to the tool it
will be considered alright after a very
nice stroll in the park
we're going to finish off the night by
making some rice krispie treats so I've
actually never made rice krispies treats
before which is kind of where it sits
like a childhood staple I'd say Isaac
are you excited to be making a very
first rice krispies treat okay yeah
[Music]
what if you guys so good are so so good
[Music]
Michael Jackson will be proud oh that's
pretty good
nice voila yeah we could to get it by by
five hey alright now it's time for
Christmas dinner and we are doing
[Music]
we're very Christmas
[Music]
all right moment of truth good mix you
want to dance like Michael Jackson Hey
the dancers are crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughter mama mama Mia
yeah my mama named you mañana
ha ha ha ha ha Oh Oh this today or on
our way Florida what's awesome okay see
you